A
VIABLE GOAL.
ROSEMARY?
>> THANKS TO PHIL BLACK,
JOINING US LIVE, FROM GLASGOW,
SCOTLAND.
NOW, WE WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME
INCREDIBLE IMAGES OF TUVALU'S
FOREIGN MINISTER, DELIVERING A
SPEECH TO THE COP26 SUMMIT,
KNEE DEEP IN SEAWATER.
WEARING A SUIT AND TIE, HE MADE
IT CLEAR, JUST HOW VULNERABLE
HIS LOW LYING, PACIFIC ISLAND
IS, TO RISING SEA LEVELS.
TUVALU IS SITUATED MIDWAY
BETWEEN HAWAII, AND AUSTRALIA.
AND HERE IS PART OF HIS
RECORDED MESSAGE.
>> AND TO VELOUR, WE LIVE THE
REALITIES OF CLIMATE, CHANGE
AND SEA LEVEL RISE.
IT'S WHAT YOU SEE HERE, AT
COP26.
WE CANNOT WAIT FOR SPEECHES
WHEN THE SEA IS RISING AROUND,
US ALL THE TIME.
CLIMATE MOBILITY MUST COME TO
THE FOREFRONT.
WE MUST TAKE BOLD, ALTERNATIVE
ACTION, TODAY, TO SECURE
TOMORROW.
>> JOINING ME NOW, TO THE LIU
FOREIGN MINISTER, SIMON
CO-FAITH, SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TALKING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, IT'S A PLEASURE.
>> YOU FILMED YOUR PLEASURE --
YOUR SPEECH FOR COP26, FOR
STANDING ME DEEP IN THE OCEAN.
THAT IMAGE HAS, ALREADY, GONE
VIRAL.
HAMMERING HOME THE IMPACT OF
RISING SEA LEVELS.
IT ESPECIALLY ON YOUR NATION,
AS WELL AS OTHERS PACIFIC
ISLANDS.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING ABOUT
THIS, IN TERMS OF GLOBAL ACTION?
>> WELL, THANK YOU.
OUR PRIME MINISTER DELIVERED A
MESSAGE, AND THEY ARE
HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN TUVALU.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE SINKING.
SO, WE THOUGHT WE COULD
DEMONSTRATE THAT IN A VIDEO.
SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN IMAGE TO
LOOK AT.
WE NEED A PIECE OF THE REACTION
OF THE PUBLIC, AND IT'S GONE
VIRAL, AND WE DIDN'T EXPECT IT
TO GO THAT FAR UP.
BUT, IT HAS.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY PLEASED WITH
THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS.
WE DO HOPE THAT IT HELPS
TRANSLATE SOME OF THESE
COMMITMENTS, INTO ACTIONS, AND
THEN WE SEE THE LEADERS TAKE A
STRONG STANCE, ON CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> ACCORDING TO THE WORLD BANK,
WESTERN PACIFIC OCEAN LEVELS
HAVE RISEN UP TO 3 TIMES FASTER,
IN THE GLOBAL AVERAGE, AND IS
THAT WHAT YOU ARE SEEING ON
YOUR ISLAND?
ASSESSING YOUR NATION'S
VULNERABILITY TO GLOBAL WARMING?
>> IN FACT, WHERE I WAS
STANDING, AND TAKING MY
STATEMENT, THAT USED TO BE LAND,
MANY YEARS AGO.
BEHIND ME, YOU CAN SEE A
CONCRETE SLAB, AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY THE FOUNDATION OF A
WORLD WAR II AREA, BUILT BY THE
U.S. MILITARY, IN 1942, I THINK
IT WAS.
THAT, WAS ACTUALLY, ON LAND.
IF YOU LOOK INTO THE VIDEO, IT
IS 20, OR 30 METERS IN THE
OCEAN, IN THE CITY.
SO, THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND SEA LEVEL RISE, IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A REALITY FOR
US, INTO VALUE.
WE WANTED TO CONVEY THAT
MESSAGE, TO PEOPLE, AND
ALTHOUGH WE ARE FACING THAT
CHALLENGE NOW, ONE DAY, IT WILL
BE OTHER PAR